hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast clinical and economic
benefits of faster phenotypic
antimicrobial susceptibility testing
presented by Levi Kerwin he is the
director of commercial marketing and
accelerate diagnostic I am Marjorie
drawers of lobbies and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth and
sponsored by accelerate diagnostic for
more information about our sponsor does
it accelerate Diagnostics calm before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and that offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits the presentation over
and we're going to look at some of the
science some of the recent publications
that speak to the need for faster
susceptibility results how those empower
clinicians to make rapid decisions at
the bedside and we'll do a brief
overview of the technology behind how
the accelerate feeding system using the
accelerate Phoenix has blood pooling
which was recently cleared by the FDA
for patients and use we'll talk a little
bit about how that works so let's start
here with the urgent clinical need for
susceptibility results getting faster if
you if you're anything at all in the
world has nothing to do with
microbiology let's pretend for a moment
that you are you are a mom taking your
kids to school let's pretend that you
are a guy working at a tire shop let's
pretend that you are anybody anywhere
the United States today who's got
Twitter Facebook and a TV connection you
are hearing about sepsis
you are hearing about multi
drug-resistant organisms
it's amazing within the last two years
that's gone from something that really
was
the world of Medicine the world of
conical precipice - right now it's
something that's on NPR and it's
something that's on your local news
station so there's people to begin about
it but nothing to do with health care
and it's because it is quickly becoming
as a The Economist Lord O'Reilly for in
the UK for the National Health Service
comment that it's becoming the leading
health issue of the next hundred years
it is considered to be by the CDC by the
World Health Organization and even by
the UN to be the critical issue facing
the global economy and this is because
not only the things that we know today
about mortality rates of substance how
it gets much worse when you have multi
drug-resistant organisms involved in the
infection but it's because of the
economic considerations of what happens
in the world we don't have and the
thought that we could possibly be back
in the dark ages without having medicine
to treat the common infections that we
have but if hearing it on the news and
if hearing it from global well known
bodies such as governmental
organizations like the UN isn't enough
here in the US we've got the stick we've
got we've got the government telling us
that you either demonstrate a robust
system for stewardship that you
demonstrate how the stewardship you're
going to properly and responsible leaves
antibiotics or we will pull you out of a
Mersenne from that here now this is a
proposed rule we don't know what the
final regulations will look like right
particularly in today's political
climate but this is this is not very
much carrot and stick this is pretty
much all stick right and so where we are
here in the US knowing the
reimbursements so heavily tied to
everything we do coming from coming from
Medicare this is this is a signet
for us all so each of you who are here
at some role in antimicrobial
stewardship right you are either here as
they as a trained IV pharmacist is we
have that Ashley here in fact we have
infection prevention directors here such
as Jared we have people here who come in
as those medical doctors but if you're
working on the web as a microbiology
manager as a mentor and you don't
formally have a position on stewardship
committee I submit to you are critical
to the role of stewardship because every
decision every piece of data that you
provide to the laboratory and the time
in which you provide it makes an
ultimate impact on how stewardship
decisions are made on that larger
picture of the strategies taken and
implemented to treat critically ill
patients and where we come in is to
provide that diagnostic information more
rapidly particularly with respect to the
susceptibility test and the m.i.c and
ultimately to get those and get those
pieces of information faster so that
your clinicians to make evidence-based
decisions using clinical decision
support software tools or other
engineering controls that you may have
such as redlining individual antibiotics
so you can make those informed therapy
decisions faster and treat the patient
improve the outcomes improve quality of
life for those who are able to get an
extra three for you you know six months
out of being able to be treated
correctly the first time as quickly as
possible and so ultimately this is
looking at improving health outcomes but
it's also looking at reducing cost
because we don't live in a world an
ideal place that's free of the
constraints of costs and free of the
constraints of money and treating
patients faster who have bacteremia
treating patients more rapidly being
able to identify but more importantly
get the right a biotic at the right dose
with the right dosing strategy with the
least collateral damage to the patient
it makes economic sense as well and
we'll look at some papers that speak to
the implications for ICU bed cost and
for the cost of antibiotics as well so
let's look at some of the science behind
Diagnostics and the role of clinical
therapy the first is let's look at
papers that talk about reducing
mortality in patients with bloodstream
infections I think this is a requirement
if you ever sit down in a room to talk
about bloodstream infections you see
very very plainly foot so that
familiarity doesn't read consent here
every hour the effective therapy is
delayed for the patient the bloodstream
infection vector dr. Kumar's paper
showed a 7.6 percent decrease in
survival rate every hour and so that
means the clock is ticking so that if we
can save 2 hours 4 hours 6 hours in our
case 40 to 50 hours you are getting on
the right side of that curve to impact
that patients outcome to impact the
difference between life and death
manipulation every hour counts for the
patient actually looking at length of
stay this is a graph that's been a
assuming a table that's been adapted
from dr. angela lung and her colleagues
paper from 2013 at the university of
michigan and what you're looking at is a
quick numerical representation of how
they've implemented rapid ID technology
using multi the traditional multi method
from Iceland together with antimicrobial
stewardship and this is an important
thing no diagnostic tool is an island it
has to be implemented together with the
people who make those decisions on how
results are taken and given to
intensivist who's treating at the
bedside so her paper doesn't fees apart
those differences both both things are
being looked at
grab that ID technology how that
improves susceptibility testing results
up a little bit but also generally how
is it used in the context of stewardship
and so what we see here is that they had
a significant decrease looking at the
top line here at time to result but more
importantly using using antimicrobial
stewardship they were able to decrease
significantly I see length of stay which
is bolded and significantly decreased
30-day mortality and there was an
association
although the true correlation with total
overall hospital I can say but you
notice those areas those are very market
decreases saving six point six days in
the ICU that Cobra patients with
bacteremia now how did they do that it
wasn't just the times I D these bottom
lines are what's important for you if
you are sitting here today as a ID
physician and I D pharmacist and
infection Preventionist is when the
therapy actually get changed when we
able to escalate to effective therapy
the smaller cohort of patients that are
on empiric therapy but none of those
innovative agents are covering the
infection are active against the
ideological agent of all and then for
that broad cohort really nearly every
patients who's being treated with
empiric therapy how quickly can you get
them on optimal therapy to deescalate to
discontinue unnecessary to get them on
the right drug at the right dose with
the least collateral damage to the
patient and the key thing is that it has
to be a partnership between the
laboratory and the stewardship team on
how those results are going to be used
repeatedly and how are they going to be
used so that decisions can be made days
nights and weekends for the critically
ill patient and this is another piece of
data from court April when they look at
what parts of diagnostic information
were used to change therapy decisions
the m.i.c value together with success
was required more than half the time to
be able to narrow therapy the grants and
identification of great value for
escalating to effective therapy that
comes to be a pretty small quote work
because most of your institutions 75 to
80% of your patients are on effective
therapy those are numbers that have been
established through four different
papers that we reference whether it's
the long paper Katherine Perez of the
Memphis health system in Texas red Omar
from the University of Sevilla Spain as
well as song 2015
also from Michigan so each of these have
shown a lot agreement about 75 to 80
percent of your patients are on
effective therapy he is so how can you
be escalate how can you do the things
that are prevent the downstream effects
such as sido such as additional cases of
multi-drug resistant organisms that
happened because you are selectively
creating the pressure to induce
antibiotic resistance so how do we
ultimately take this together in
advanced stewardship again let's talk
about sido because the government's
talking about C though because your
administrators you're talking about
you're probably in fact sick of hearing
the word C though right you're hearing
this all the time your stewardship
meetings I like to talk about this this
is a fantastic paper this is
big numbers eat this is a retrospective
study that was nynuk kaiser this was
looking at the entire Kaiser network
this was published just that the the end
of 2015 in December by Car Talk and
colleagues retrospective review of four
hundred and three thousand plus patient
records that's some work and there's a
lot of great insights here where they
tease apart different correlations and
associations between what's happening
with the patient and when does see the
incidence increase this is one of the
key findings looking at the graph on
your right you see the rate that the
incidence as a percentage of the entire
inpatient population of Sita and a
simultaneous number of drug classes
administered and when you go from one
drug which is the red column to three or
more drugs which is the yellow column to
fivefold incidence and Sita with a very
strong statistical correlation there's
many other insights on opening the time
to go in here but just go back look at
the paper and see some of the additional
insights they have a specific
antibiotics such as fluoroquinolone use
and Bank oh my sinews and the increased
risk of pseudo impacts patient outcomes
it affects the spread of Sita for every
grandmother and every daughter and every
niece and nephew who's walking in and
out of that room it impacts the hostel
acquired right right spread of Sita for
every healthcare worker is going in and
out of that room but again it has
impacts for you too stewards on on
reducing antibiotic usage and costs if
you can get those patients on the right
therapy and deescalate faster that
patient could be moved to your stuff
down that patient can immediately
Arisa may exceed another great paper
we're not going to look at but look at
this recent paper that's published in
January of this year from the UK
National Health Service a great
retrospective review that followed the
patients through two or three different
regions within the NHS and has very
strong correlation to reducing
penicillin use and fluoroquinolone use
specifically and how that tied back to
lower see the phrase in the UK but again
it all comes back to the bottom line -
right because you have the healthcare
acquired conditions let you go around
the hack reduction program that is now
measuring see that is one of those eight
core measures under the PSI 90 and if
you are not in the if you're in that
bottom 25% I should say you're being
faced with a one percent cut when you
all Medicare reimbursement so you're not
not to keep wielding the heavy stick I'm
just I'm just the messenger
don't shoot the messenger right this is
important and part of what we do is
partner with you not only the escalate
so effective therapy which is critical
for the mortality benefit to patients
but it's also to reduce these downstream
effects for patients who can get off of
all of those additional antibiotics as
quickly as possible this is an example
of some of the results that we have from
our system this is a patient record
clinical trial and this is the kind of
patient that when we talked to a couple
of our ID physicians many pharmacists
that we have our scientific advisory
board adjacent Pogo Detroit Medical
Center Jim Lewis at the Oregon Health
Sciences University and when they look
at this they say this is the kind of
patient we see every day
the this patient comes in they at least
two of four service symptoms show there
immediately
they draw back take the drugs and says
what culture bottles and most likely
they're moving into the ICU if it's not
already there but the results come back
if you have something like this looking
on the right-hand side you're seeing
that everything here is susceptible
based off the MSE for all of the
different formulary choices that we have
available on our system and if you have
access to an arguable agreement you
would see a Kalista results here as well
we also test for callosum
we do have pants acceptable results I'd
like to I know we have an IV pharmacist
in the room so actually if you don't
mind I'll put you on the spot here you
get this patient how quickly from the
lab today how quickly we do get results
back that the m.i.c was susceptibility
normally
okay 1830 hours of it right away
and so actually your waiting list let's
just call it 48 hours that tends to be
pretty quick and see what man showed
there were their recent study they have
48 hours the susceptibility result you
get this result you have an e.coli
that's been susceptible the patients
stabilized not seeing any additional
problems what would you do for a
treatment social devastation
if possible you might have had a patient
like this on an anti sue them oh that's
part of my hair so you might be able to
remove at least two antibiotics they may
be on hands like bumble of the time okay
well go on by the hero I like to always
ask to the idea pharmacist entering
first and I put up a base set to let's
see I mean if our other any pharmacist
agree that's it's the exact same thing
right the first insight from token Lewis
says if I know that if I see and I see
where I'm susceptible it doesn't just
give me one or two options I can look at
all the different choices based off of
what I know about this patient because
again it's not just the susceptibility
results it's that whole host of factors
that you've had available in the chart
what are the other comorbidities what
else is involved but knowing this I can
deescalate maybe to a first or second
generation cephalosporin I can put them
on something very very low bioburden to
the patient that is going to reduce the
risk of Sita for this patient as well as
get them back down the step-down just
quicker pressing on these are the sort
of insights you can have of our system
again including being able to listen
results were needed for a multi drug
resistant organism here's another way to
think about this so I didn't fix my
mouth forgive me that let's assume you
have four patient bacteremic patients
per day
let's work the graph on the Left shows
that this is a month of patients where
you've got your sending for a unique
positive blood cultures per day so 120
in a month
that's your institution and this is this
is an average or in us institutions many
of you come from much bigger
institutions many of you come from
institutions search for the right in
this in this spot based off of the long
paper again 52% of the time you would
need to have the susceptibility result
to be able to escalate so if you're
giving those faster ASP results based
off of our clinical trial a of 40 hours
faster than current methodologies across
a who issue of clinical institutions and
returning to microbial stewardship team
is ready to act has the tools in place
has the resources in place to be able to
act across all shows can you roll up can
you begin to accelerate therapy
decisions faster can you maybe move from
only changing therapy when your
pharmacist makes rounds in the ICU every
day to begin doing it within every
couple of hours right this is the kind
of thing that you can do at this tool
again rapid IV helps we don't we don't
plan to be a fix-all you have molecular
technology or MALDI that you're getting
a significant benefit cuz the IDE to
help to deescalate but how many
positions are deescalate non-id long how
many will accept that data is the epic a
on the escalator the ASDs was needed so
the finally reducing the cost of care
the ICU length of stay is the largest
cost drivers all of your institutions
are looking at treating the battery
information it's a fact it's the nature
of the cost of carrots day and the
America
one day of the icy ranges from $2,500
for a rural institution to $15,000 plus
for a specialty of children's
institution or oncology institution and
so this is up to 60 times the cost of a
single venous blood culture the
economics end up working out well
because what we're looking at it's not
simply using this for a very small
percentage of patients but this is able
to be used for ninety to ninety-five
percent of your patients based off of
the prevalence of the organisms that we
have on our panel and this helps you to
reduce something ICU costs but again
under than a much smaller level
antibiotic costs as well like the
escalating and discontinuing unnecessary
therapy so your net hospital savings
becomes what you save in the ICU plus
antibiotic costs subtracted from the net
line cost of reaming at the accelerate
the--not system so here's how the system
works is just a quick overview it makes
me fully automated be able to run very
simply and easily by any technician in
your lab it's m.i.c based direct
susceptibility results direct from the
positive blood culture specimen to help
you to expedite antibiotic therapy and
personalized optimizing therapy for each
patient base off the MSE and the
scalable design allows us to put this in
very small institutions to institutions
who are running eight ten twelve twenty
positive blood cultures per day by being
able multiple units interface together
you get results in under 90 minutes per
oggi and then just under five hours
later you're going to get the myc
susceptibility result for a total time
to result under seven hours our clinical
trial average was six hours and 41
minutes and within the 95 percentile of
all results reported we were under seven
hours and five minutes so we stay
results in about seven hours you'll
never have any resulting longer than
eight if that fast and has that reliably
fast and reproducibly fast for your
clinicians takes five hundred
microliters a positive light culture
specimen transfer to the sample while
the user pushes
into the system and presses start no
additional steps centrifugation by
petting washing with Elias buffer it is
that simple the reason is we want to be
able to empower many of you who have
these centralized labs to be able to
decentralized when possible and bring
testing closer to the patient at the
patient bedside this can be anywhere
that there's a blood blood incubator at
any place where you've got a blood
culture system like a backpack the you
can bring in the pheno system around it
as well we have an addition to the ID
and the m.i.c result susceptibility we
provide this a lot of microbial alert
which rules out the polymicrobial
infection it's a powerful additional
piece of information that no one else
provides when our system reports the 90
target and says it is mono microbial
result it means that you can rule out
with ninety nine point six percent
positive predictive value the presence
of the polymicrobial infection this
means you can deescalate it now it's the
trigger to deescalate immediately when
you receive this result and for most of
you run into the system 80% of the time
plus you're going to get a mono
microbial call but this polymicrobial
infections' typically make up by the 10%
of all infections with with patients of
bacteria now of course I'm the
respiratory world with lower respiratory
infections polymicrobial are level we
are with our planet colu capability we
record up to three ID targets and will
report the dominant ast for a mixed
mixed infection will just report with a
one ASU than M IC for that dominant
organism we have future work already
game time and we're working on putting
together the CD submission in Europe for
lower respiratory for the AL
and we're continuing to do the initial
research work on skin and soft tissue as
well surgical site infections so this is
a system that will grow and continue to
expand for all of the critically ill
patients who are suffering from
bacterial infection and again we also do
cover a few targets for pancha as well
another way was just seeing on the
polyworks we use a mixture of universal
probes and then specialized fish probes
that target based off of a concern 16s
rRNA sequence and what we're doing is
being able to then light up in co-locate
signal based off of which which signals
they get that light up as bacteria and
in the specialized target probes that
light up they saw actually so here we're
looking at an example on the right of a
mixed infection of e.coli Osetra factor
we can clearly and easily identify which
organisms are which and then reliably
provide the ASD for the dominant
organism as well if you haven't seen
this before from one of our commercial
development directors I think this one
screen is the best and quickest way so I
can get time for all of our speakers
today to say what it is we do we're
taking thousands of time-lapse
high-definition images of each
individual cell that's why we did it
introduced into the flow cells on our
consumable system with our unit has
blood culture kit and that's what you
see in the lower right corner we then
generate 30 different more phonetic
feature analyses these are everything
from size and shape of cells as they
grow the size and shape of the entire
micro calling how the daughter cells
divide but that's the morphology piece
on the kinetic side we measure star
cavity we measure the vision rate over
time we measure kill rate over time
we're looking at all of these different
pieces of
patience that we generate the
information that awfully correlates to a
very broad library of tens of thousands
of note templates of m.i.c response so
that from a single antibiotic
concentration we can provide that
reliable hem I see that then is
translated into the customizable m.i.c
interpretation whether using clsi or
some other set of interpretation results
and this is the key input for pk/pd
calculations for where it's needed right
in the lab particularly for your ad
pharmacist who needs this to calculate
based on the therapy and what does this
ultimately do them for you it's reducing
the time from interior optimal therapy
this graph represents not a an
accelerated promise this represents the
comparison at thirteen different
clinical sites looking at over 1,800
specimens that were run and we were over
40 hours faster on average across these
13 sites that are really a who's who of
clinical practice so when you're here
today and listening to a Christopher due
to dr. Watkins who have implemented this
technology and are beginning to measure
their results we're beginning to see how
the results actually impacted specific
patient lives giving you the background
in data that I encourage you to test in
question since we have time today thank
you we provide current to that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is we use the
antibiogram at our facility in
conjunction with ID why would I need ASD
results to have the doctor choose
therapy okay thank you thanks for that
question
um yeah so good question this is a very
common a very common thing right the the
antibiogram has been relied upon as
as the best sort of rubric writer the
best decision-making tool for helping
physicians to choose an antibiotic
course or antibiotic regimen in the
absence of complete microbiology
diagnostic results from the lab and the
reason why they've chosen this right is
because when you think about
traditionally how a physician would
receive results from the lab they don't
get everything up front you go back
fifty years all the way through to today
and unless they have a an accelerated
female system then what they're doing is
they're waiting 12 to 24 hours to get
the first acknowledgement the blood
culture model has popped positive so the
patient is already on empiric therapy
because they've matched two of the four
symptoms for sirs their condition has
not improved and so they've been started
on two three antibiotics four grand
positive gram-negative coverage and in
the case of certain high-risk patients
they'll have additional gram-negative
coverage for anti-suit ammonal like for
example cefepime
and then they'll be added to that for
again a smaller category of high-risk
patients they'll be on an antifungal of
some kind like amphotericin B for
example so they're they're waiting for
results and they get them piecemeal if
you get them spread apart over a
significant period of time the blood
culture bottle result is between 12 to
24 hours before they get that result
called in to them
it's another 1 to 2 hours before they
get the Gram stain result called in and
it's a critical result of standards one
hour but it can be longer and then
they're waiting for ideal result so this
varies widely from laboratories that
have recently adopted a molecular
platform it might get the result called
in in two to four hours MALDI it's going
to be 24 to 30 hours from waiting for
the culture and then for all of the
traditional microbiology systems for ID
they're waiting between 24 to 36 hours
between the time that the solid media
has enough organisms on it to show
growth and then they test and this is
still waiting another 24 hours before
they can get susceptibility results
right whether they drop discs or whether
they're going on to it to a traditional
susceptibility platform like like the
vitek or the
so the challenge is what do doctors do
when they don't have perfect information
well they develop the antibiogram to
look at the historical record of the
susceptibility profile of organisms that
are most commonly involved in
bloodstream infections and you look at
the challenges of the antibiogram all
the antibiogram does is it tells you
what historically going back a year or
two years by specimen source in some
cases otherwise it can be all one done
what is the the most common
susceptibility of an organism by
antibiotic that a hospital chooses in
the formulary and when you're looking
particularly at gram negatives you're
looking at organisms that typically are
only 70 to 75 percent susceptible to the
common empiric therapy agents there's
been several research papers at the
University of Michigan Methodist Health
Center and other places that have shown
that empiric therapy only is effective
therapy about 75 percent of the time so
what they're doing is making a best
guess that means 25 to 30% of the time
the patient is not on effective therapy
all of those antibiotics are not working
but by using the antibiogram there
they're doing the best possible guess
right using using a science or they are
available to track us oracle trims the
definitive result though for getting the
patient on the right drug at the right
dose with the least collateral damage
based off of adverse effects is
providing the m.i.c result with a
susceptibility interpretation they
sought which other guidelines you're
using so the Biograph is good when you
don't have a faster phenotypic
susceptibility test to tell you what to
do but now laboratories are using the
pheno test system they're getting all of
those results together at once getting
rid of the delay between when the tests
are posted into the patient's electronic
record and when the physician can act
and so this means that getting the ASC
result together with the ID in less than
seven hours from from blood culture
positivity the physicians make a
decision based off the evidence for that
patient customized by individual choice
based off of that
patience profile in that patients
biology rather than using a historical
record and so it's just where science is
now leading medicine to go in terms of
best possible practice with
individualized therapy and
individualized medicine and and so again
that's that's where the FINA tests can
advance the practice of medical care in
the hospital thank you thank you our
next question is we have a bio fire
system that gives ID and resistance
markers in about two hours the joy
system provide evidence of resistance
okay great great question so the the
identification result that the bio fire
or that the the pheno test blood culture
kit would give on the pheno system
you'll you'll still get a complete panel
of grand positive and gram negative
targets we also add the two most common
a candida species targets that are
involved in Candida mia but the the
resistance marker all a resistance
marker does is give you a positive or a
negative call for a resistance gene we
go further than that by providing the
complete susceptibility profile by
organism and antibiotic combination with
the m.i.c together with the
susceptibility interpretation they
sought whichever susceptibility
guidelines you're using which for most
US labs will be you know the clsi
guidelines for in a National Labs this
may be the you cast guidelines and so
what this means is think of it this way
the resistance marker right and
particularly if gram negatives if it's a
positive result it tells you that the
resistance marker is present that rules
out a certain antibiotic or a certain
group of antibiotics it can rule that
out but when it comes to particularly
gram negatives a negative resistance
marker result does not rule in the
capability to provide and to go ahead
and dose with a more narrow spectrum
antibiotic and here's the reason why
there are poor in mutations there are a
flux pumps there are different
conformational changes in the membrane
that are observed these known mechanisms
that are outside of genotype that are
phenotypically expressed when organisms
in
and particularly in the gram-negative in
a Rebecca in neuro bacteria ACA class
are exposed antibiotics and so what
phenotypic susceptibility does is get
beyond those limitations and further
rather than giving a present absent it
gives the mi C which is that definitive
diagnostic result for choosing the dose
the dosing strategy for the given
antibiotic and at the least collateral
damage possible so this allows a
clinician to see at a glance what the
organism is susceptible to so they can
choose narrow spectrum antibiotics they
can deescalate whereas the resistance
marker choice really can only be used
for escalation in a very large number of
patient cases given additional
comorbidities so the susceptibility
result being the definitive diagnostic
result for choosing an antibiotic having
that m.i.c available allows the
clinician to then deescalate and reduce
the impact of selective pressures that
lead to multi-drug resistance in that
patient being a locus for the spread of
multi-drug resistance elsewhere in the
hospital and most critically given
today's healthcare environment it
reduces the pressures that produce c
diff infections and there's significant
numbers of papers that show correlation
between multiple classes of antibiotic
and c diff infection so having that
result it does more than just select the
right antibiotic for the patient today
it means we have antibiotics for
patients for the future as well
and so that's where we extend and go
further than what a just a resistance
marker alone would do all right thank
you for your question thank you our next
question is is implemented multi and you
by tech to and very gene in the past
three years each time it took nearly a
year to complete verification and iqcp
how long does it take to complete
verification with Athena okay great
question you sound like a microbiologist
who's who's actually lived this before
I'm guessing you may have lost a little
hair from pulling it out as you were
working to get one of these systems
verified you know listen MALDI
and some of the molecular tests have
revolutionized microbiology in the past
these technologies that are now between
five to fifteen years old have have
meant that you can get a faster ID
result but when they were introduced
into the laboratory there there really
was not a lot of thoughtfulness on how
to convert a life science research
technology into something that a
clinical microbiologist could quickly
and rapidly assimilate I teach to to a
med tech and then have them begin to use
and so the verification protocol is I'm
sure you're you know that more even than
than I Do's the verification protocol
requires you to test across the set of
targets in this case ID targets that are
that are tested on the system as well as
in the case of a molecular platform like
a bio fire or barraging you also have to
test a variety of resistant and
susceptible organisms for those
resistance monitor targets what we've
done it accelerate is we we look back at
the historical record on how
verifications have been done by
interviewing hundreds of microbiologists
around the world and in getting what are
those pain points and what are those
challenges that are needed to make a
verification go faster
what has slowed down a verification in
the past and how can we help so what we
did is we put together a complete
performance verification protocol that
has a a series of different choices that
are pre mapped out that include the
right seeded isolates to test the across
the breadth of resistance or
susceptibility by organism as well as to
thoughtfully select the right organisms
across a panel to make up for gaps in
your local ideology where for example
you may not see a Sunita bacter cases
right or sericia cases more than once or
twice in a year and we've created that
so we can provide all the organisms up
front we provide the support with a
trained microbiologist who we have hired
as a technical Application Specialist
and so what we've done is we created a
protocol and in fact three different
choices of protocols that can be run
within sixty days when you take into
account additional data analysis and
capturing and final decisions typically
it's 90 days to go live from the time
that verification starts and so we we
found that looking at how microbiology
has progressed in advance while taking
to account the recent changes in clsi
standards and the iqcp
standard from CLIA as of 2016 we're
taking to that account you have a single
verification that supports iqcp supports
go live within 90 days and if you have
any questions about that I want to see
examples I have my contact information
here and I'd be happy to chat with you
thank you thank you for that answer
our last it looks like we have time for
one more question our last question is
how many places in the US are using the
pheno system ok great so right now we
have over 200 modules placed worldwide
we have in the United States we have
nearly a hundred and eighty modules that
have been placed or in the process of
being installed of those we have a
select handful that have completed
verification and are going they're
actually gone live and a reporting
patient results
but this represents over 40 hospitals in
the United States that are currently
verifying or have gone live with the
accelerate penal system
all right thank you for your question
but I think we have time for one more
question looks like by my clock let's go
ahead and try to get that
okay our last question is how much time
does it take to run each tag how many
times can you run at one okay great so a
test is we provide the identification
result and that crosses the to the lis
within an average of an hour and 21
minutes we can think of it another way
about 1.3 hours and then the system
automatically continues on to ast
results and that ast results provided on
average about 5 hours later so the total
time to result you get the ID and the
susceptibility result based off of our
clinical trial the average of 6 hours
and 43 minutes to time to result so an
ID comes first
thus accessibility test result comes
later the system is designed to have up
to 8 modules connect together and pass
through a single lis interface so a lab
can run up to 8 specimens at a time from
a positive blood culture and again as a
reminder the positive blood culture it's
two minutes hands on time maximum
between loading the sample vial loading
the FINA test blood culture kit into the
system and pressing start and I
encourage you to go to our website here
after this or here on the or use the
virtual demo that you have here on the
lab routes site and take a look at how
that works and how the loading of the
system works if you have any more
questions okay thank you I would like to
once again thank Levi Curran for his
presentation I would also like to thank
black roots and accelerate Diagnostics
for making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through December 2017 you will receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available
through replay please share that
announcements with your colleagues who
may have missed today's lab bet that's
all for now and thank you for joining us
and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye